one family has more than usual to
celebrate this graduation season the
Flies don't have just one graduate they
have five spanning three generations
Dean Reynolds brings us the story of
this inspirational family in Beecher
Illinois it was a special day for
lawanda flah noi for 25 years she worked
full-time to raise her three daughters
so finally earning an associate degree
this month was especially sweet am I
gonna want to hug but the best part is
that her children are graduating from
school - all at the same time so this is
like a happy coincidence
absolutely yeah not so much for me it's
expensive for me Amaury just graduated
[ __ ] laude from the University of
Illinois at Chicago and is heading off
to a job with Ford Harris just graduated
from Chicago State and has a job with
Apple Jade is graduating from high
school and preparing to attend Illinois
State and four-year-old granddaughter
Brooklyn is about to graduate from
pre-kindergarten if you're keeping score
that's three generations five family
members all graduating in 2017 I suppose
you must have seen yourself as a role
model I just saw myself as their mother
and taking on the role of a mother and
making sure that they're the best person
that they can be and was she a role
model absolutely absolutely we wouldn't
be here today yeah sitting right here
without her what was the feeling when
you were up there on the stage it was
overwhelming
what did you all think when you saw your
mother
that's really exciting just because this
is something that we've been working
towards for so long but to actually see
her do it in it you know the focus be
one heard was something that was really
really exciting and lawanda flah noi
isn't stopping she plans to get her
bachelor's degree in psychology as soon
as she can
it sounds like you have very high goals
for yourself in addition to your
children absolutely absolutely I have to
set an example and that she has good job
it's a good job thank you baby
you're next for CBS this morning Dean
Reynolds Beecher
Illinois there's an American story that
belief and education is a key to your
future and it is never too late to go
back and get that degree right pleh know
why women go I know congratulations to
all of them